[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Welcome to
this afternoon's session,
"Migrating to Cloud Spanner."
My name is Sami Zuhuruddin.
I'm a staff solution
architect with Google Cloud.
I'm joined today by Niel
from across the pond.
We're both going to spend the
next 45, 50 minutes with you
going over all
kinds of scenarios
on migrating from digital tape
archives to Cloud Spanner.
Just kidding.
We're not going to talk
about digital tape archives
to Cloud Spanner.
Hopefully, that's
a different talk.
If you need that talk,
talk to me afterwards.
So most likely, you're
coming from much more
contemporary frameworks, much
more interesting database
choices.
And really, what we want to
do today is talk about that.
I'm going to talk
about Cloud Spanner.
If you're here,
hopefully, that's
because something
externally enticed
you to want to look at what
a migration would look like.
But we'll go over,
real quick, what
the background is
on Cloud Spanner
and why you would
want to consider it.
We'll talk about,
in general, how
we've thought about migrations
and how Niel and I have
put together sort of
a sequence of steps
that we think applies to
most organizations in the way
that they're going to
approach a migration.
But we really want to
make it practical for you.
We've chosen a couple
of case studies
that we'll walk
through, step by step,
and show how you would
go from a source system
into Cloud Spanner.
So, hopefully, you will leave
here with something tangible.
And then, finally, we'll wrap
up with some closing thoughts.
Hopefully, that sounds fair.
So a quick background
on Cloud Spanner.
It's internally used
within Google as Spanner.
It is our transactional
record of state
for hundreds of applications.
And it was born not sort
of in the beginning.
In the beginning, Google was
busy solving how to index
the internet and sort of find
all of these massive patterns
and provide meaningful search.
And it wasn't something
that was initially
tackled until it became
critical that we did tackle it
based on the size of
some of our businesses.
But when we did, we
realized a lot of challenges
that we were
overcoming are faced
by a lot of organizations.
How do you, at scale,
maintain a database
with high reliability,
high durability,
transactional throughput,
something that can be
used in financial transactions?
And so Cloud Spanner's the
externalization of that.
We realized a lot of customers
have the same challenges
and have gone down different
paths to try to solve it.
So if you are coming from that
sort of, hey, broad use of data
but have had to make
trade-offs in the past, had
to decide on what you're
willing to give up,
hopefully, this talk will
be applicable to you.
It's enterprise-grade.
Google uses it to run a
multibillion dollar enterprise.
We have other customers
using it, as well.
But really, it's designed,
with a high SLA in mind,
to be strictly consistent.
It is ACID compliant.
And it's distributed.
It's the thing that a
lot of organizations
try to solve with
distributed architectures,
with the multi-server
approach, with multi-nodes,
with a lot of interconnect and
a lot of distributed storage.
It is all that.
But instead, it's just a
database behind an API.
It gives you all that
distributed nature,
but you don't really have to
do much to get through to it.
It's relational in nature.
So relational data is
like the easiest thing
to get your head around if
you've been around databases.
It's been around for
a very long time.
It's something anybody
can sort of reason
about when they go from
one team to another.
Within Google, we value
developer time considerably.
And it doesn't
make a lot of sense
to have developers move
from one team to another
and sort of have to say, well,
what storage are you using?
How are you using it?
What are their
canonical queries?
Everybody sort of gets SQL
and gets the relational model,
pretty well.
And so there's a very
little, low friction point
to move saliently between teams
and say, oh, yeah, I know.
You're using Spanner
at the back end?
I can get going on that.
And it's horizontally scalable.
It's not much.
It's not this sort of
heavy-handed, you can scale up,
but you can't scale down.
And it's not where you have
to make a capacity request.
That's where kind of
poke an API and you
get a lot more transactional
throughput through to it.
To spin it up,
it's pretty simple.
You name the instance, choose a
region, pick a number of nodes,
and hit Create.
I just wanted to show
that, because I thought
it was a pretty cool animation.
I didn't make it.
So really, you just have
to reason about two things,
and then I'll turn
it over to Niel.
And naming in computer
science is everything, right?
So you have to name it.
But then you have to
pick how many nodes.
Nodes is really just
your unit of capacity.
It is the most
sensitive thing to cost.
You pick how many
nodes you need.
And we'll go through what each
node gives you in a little bit.
And then where do you want it?
So how much capacity do
you want and where do you
want it, which region?
Do you want multi-region?
The product comes in a lot
of different varieties.
And the last thing
is take your code,
merge it together with
our client libraries
or speak SQL to us, and
then you're ready to go.
We understand DDL as a database.
So things that you're used
to doing in other databases
are pretty easy to use.
Similar to BigQuery
and other products,
there is a built-in
query window.
So that's the basic.
What I described takes
longer than it actually
does to actually get
started with Cloud Spanner.
So now let's talk
about migrations,
how we're going to talk about
the rest of the programs we're
going to walk through in
terms of the migration,
practical examples.
Neal's going to
talk through that.
NIEL MARKWICK: So, hi there.
My name's Niel Markwick.
I'm a solution
architect from Belgium.
And so in this
section, I'm going
to give a general framework
for migrations, giving you
a high level plan of
action for migrating
your application from the
existing database to Cloud
Spanner.
So the first step,
you need to isolate
all your database access code.
If you've got it distributed
in various modules
in your application,
including any lines of code,
it's best to isolate that
all into a separate module.
And that will be the
one place where you have
all your database access code.
And be sure your
development team
only adds new code
in that module,
so you know exactly what
code talks to the database
and exactly what code needs be
changed during the migration
process.
In general, this is
a very good practice.
Because it gives you one single
module to test your database
interactions.
And similarly, it
enables your unit testing
of your application.
You only need one single
model module to mock out.
You don't need to
have a test database.
You don't need to have some
weird and wonderful way
of creating some
data that takes care
of some weird, wonderful
edge conditions.
You can mock all that out
and supply this bad data
to the rest of your
application to test how
your application handles it.
It makes it a lot easier
to find and analyze
any complex SQL queries you've
got in your application.
And it gives you a single
point to add metrics and alerts
for monitoring your
database access.
For instance, you could add
an alert for query latency,
so that you know when
your queries are starting
to get a bit slow, it's time
to resize your database,
add more power.
Or you see which particular
queries are slow,
so you don't need to dive deeper
to find out why they're slow.
Maybe optimize the
query a bit better,
change the way things
are read, perhaps.
It also allows you,
with the metrics,
to check the frequency of
reads to the tables, which
may give you an indication
of whether you can add
some client-side caching
to your database layer,
thus giving a performance
boost to your application,
because it no longer needs
to read from the database.
It can get it from
the local cache.
And of course, failure alerts,
so any read-write failures,
any inconsistency
problems, you got
to place to alert it and
catch the problem before it
starts getting really bad.
And, as I said, you've
got a single isolated
module for migration.
So your next step is to add
the code to that module that
reads and writes to Spanner.
Sounds simple.
But we'll look into more
details about that later.
You'll be reading and
writing at the same time
as reading or writing from
the original database.
You would include capabilities,
in your application, that
are not available in Spanner.
Again, more on that later.
And the code would be
reading to and writing
from both, at the
same time, but you'd
have one database as
your source of truth.
At the beginning,
of course, it would
be your original database.
And once you've fully
migrated your data over
and you're sure there's
no inconsistencies,
you can switch to Cloud Spanner
as your source of truth.
So when you're writing to
a database, to Spanner,
you should update
the entire row.
You shouldn't just
update the columns.
And that way, you're ensuring
that the data you're writing
to Spanner is fully up to date.
On reads, you can read
from both databases
and compare any
inconsistencies and report
those inconsistencies.
Again, this is to
gain confidence
that your migration is
happening correctly.
And once all your
data is imported
and everything is
synchronized, there
should be no inconsistency,
so no more failures.
One other thing you
should be doing,
if you do deletions of
rows in your database,
you should keep a log of these.
When you are
importing data, rows
might have already been deleted.
So you don't want
to be recreating
these rows you've already
deleted whilst you're
doing your import.
Keeping a log of
the deletions will
allow you to check whether
this row has been deleted
when you're re-importing it.
And finally, one really useful
thing is commit timestamps.
Some databases do
this automatically.
In Spanner, it's an option.
You have a column, which
is the timestamp when
that row has been committed.
And you can use this to know
which is the latest data
version, whether it's the
data you are importing
or it's the data that's
already been written
by your application to Spanner.
And also, this module--
one other thing--
allows you to canary the
use of your new database.
You switch the source's
truth partially.
You can still have some
application instances
talking to Spanner
and some talking
to the original database.
So if you catch any problems
early, you can rollback.
So how would you
actually migrate?
Well, a simple method.
You convert your database
schema to Cloud Spanner schema
and create your database.
You shut down your application.
You do your export and import
whilst your database is not
being written to, so
it's completely stable.
And you start it up again.
This is not an ideal
path for several reasons.
Firstly, there's no rollback.
Your application, if
you start noticing,
after a couple of days,
things are going wrong,
some data is getting
corrupted, what do you do?
You can't rollback, because you
got a couple of days' new data.
You can't fix the data.
You just might start panicking.
If you rollback, you've lost the
data, and you have a problem.
And secondly, your
application is down.
If you are moving
to Spanner, it's
presumably because you
want to take advantage
of the scalability
and the availability,
so you wouldn't want
the downtime associated
with an export and an
import of a large data set.
So what do we do?
We want a live
migration process.
Once again, you start
with the same way.
You create your database
on Cloud Spanner,
and you export and import
from your original database
to Spanner.
But this time, you let the
application stay running.
Now, of course, whilst your
application is running,
your exported data is
already out of date.
But that's not a
problem, because we'll
see you write to both.
You keep the original database,
as your source of truth,
and continue updating
rows in Spanner.
There will still be some
instance inconsistencies,
but that's why your
original database is still
the source of truth.
Then, whilst that's
going on, you
do another import and export
of any changes that have
occurred since the last export.
Now this will bring
your data in sync
provided that you only write
rows that haven't already
been updated.
So you also, at this
point, replay any deletions
that have occurred.
And when this is
completed, it should
be that your Cloud Spanner
database is fully in sync
with your original database.
And the monitoring that you've
added in your database access
layer will not be showing any
more inconsistencies, will not
be showing any more errors.
You can repeat this last step
as many times as you want.
And at this stage, you can
also run a massive compare
to see if everything is in sync.
Finally, when you are
convinced everything is good--
not finally, sorry.
You switch to be this Cloud
Spanner is the source of truth.
Again, like I
mentioned before, you
can do this as a
canarying process.
You can partially switch
some application instances
or a percentage of the traffic,
and then monitor things,
see if everything is
good and gradually
increase the
percentages which is
being written to Cloud Spanner.
And if things go wrong, you
can immediately rollback.
Because your original database
is still being written,
you've got a perfect
rollback position to go to.
You won't lose any data.
Everything's fine.
But if everything
has gone forward,
everything is working well,
and everything's fixed,
then you can turn
off the code that
writes to your
original database,
turn off your original
database, shut it down,
and you're fully
running on Spanner.
And at this point, of course,
you have your launch party.
And you're back to Sami, now,
who will talk about the example
from migrating from a NoSQL
database to Cloud Spanner.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: I really
wanted to have a party.
NIEL MARKWICK: Yeah.
Later.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Later?
OK.
NIEL MARKWICK: After
we finish this talk.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Let's see.
Big button.
Migrating from NoSQL--
so the obvious thing
here is that Spanner is
not a NoSQL database.
But we have a lot of
customers and a lot
of interest for customers
coming to us and saying,
hey, I made these design
choices in my application
stack a while ago,
where I couldn't
scale in a relational database,
a traditional relational
database very easily.
And so I had to decide what
I was going to give up.
And most of the
time, organizations
chose to give up
transactional consistency.
Hey, let's give up transactional
consistency, because then we
can shard, really easily.
Or they decided,
you know what, we'll
maintain a relational
database, but we'll
employ some sort of shim,
some sort of sharding shim,
and so we're not really
getting true transactions
across the entire
database in one context,
but we'll have to sort of
manipulate it and introduce
some plumbing in between.
So really, the
point of this slide
is that you can have your
cake and eat it, too.
Spanner takes care of that.
It takes care of that ongoing,
true horizontal scalability,
while giving you
transactional consistency,
while giving you the ability
to keep a very high up time.
And then it gets you back
to a very simplistic model,
where you're not having to
deal with, is this key value,
is it document?
What is the underlying storage?
This is very simple to
understand SQL semantics.
So when does it apply?
So when would you do this?
You wouldn't do this
for something that
is highly volatile in nature.
So if you're just
keeping track of the key,
and then you have an arbitrary
number of attributes associated
with that, and it's really
hard for you to get a grasp of,
is there a well-known consistent
pattern to the attributes
we're keeping track of, with the
thought that those attributes
would translate to
columns, then this wouldn't
be a pattern for you to follow.
This would be, really, if
you're like, generally,
we're using it as a way to keep
track of certain attributes.
The collection or the
set of those attributes
is relatively static.
Maybe some attributes add,
here or there, but that's OK.
We can do schema
changes within Spanner.
But it's not too varied.
It's not too all over the place.
Reasonably high volume--
Spanner is a running
service, which
means you instantiate a certain
amount of capacity to it.
So if you're only,
say, transacting
with the database
at a trickle volume,
it's just some sort of
light lookup or something,
that's not it.
The use cases we're seeing
are folks that are saying,
I'm wholesale running a
massively high transactional
throughput beyond
just a light workload.
The source database should
have a pretty easy way--
I think most
databases, today, will
have a pretty easy way to
import and export data,
so much like what
Niel was mentioning--
not yet-- much
like what Niel was
mentioning in the migration
general framework.
And the last thing
is it's a real plus
if the source system has
some sort of mechanism
to do the equivalent
of change data capture.
If you can sort of know
what's coming in and out
of that database, it's great.
Some source examples, that
we're seeing a lot of,
are folks that are running
their own Mongo infrastructure,
own Cassandra infrastructure,
that also want to get out
of that pattern, but
also folks coming
from more traditional or
more service offerings,
like DynamoDB.
So we're going to
pick one of these
to walk through a migration.
Anybody want to take a guess?
Right, so DynamoDB.
So it's pretty straightforward.
It's actually not that complex.
DynamoDB is a single
table structure.
It's not many tables
related to one.
It has some nice,
interesting similarities
with regards to Cloud
Spanner in terms of the way
keys are laid out.
But it is a table.
And we're going to go through
a straightforward path.
This kind of
aligns, very nicely,
to what Niel was
talking about, where
we're going to have a
bulk loading path that's
going to come in through
certain export features.
And then we'll have our trickle
feeding, our streaming path.
We'll collate those onto the
blue icons or Google Cloud.
We'll basically coalesce
those onto the cloud side,
bring those together, using
a technology on our side,
a product called
Cloud Data Flow.
And then they'll make
their way into Spanner.
So let's build this together.
Homework, before
you get started,
is to estimate how much Cloud
Spanner capacity you will use.
Generally, there are some
rules of thumb with regards
to how much storage
should be allocated
per any number of nodes.
So if you think you'll be
strained on the storage
side of things, you
would need to scale up
the number of nodes.
And so it's basically
a quota system
of two terabytes per node--
two terabytes per node.
So if you are going
to exceed that,
you just want to
overshoot that to allocate
enough nodes to cover that.
If you're well within
that, then you're
going to design on the side of
throughput in Spanner, which
is how much transactional
throughput do I need,
which is the second point.
So now I know how
much storage I have.
How much I/O do I
have on this database?
And then understand
the data model.
Where am I coming from?
So in the case of a
DynamoDB origination,
Dynamo has a couple
of choices for how its
structures its primary keys.
Is it hash or is
it hash plus range?
Like we said in the last slide,
then, across all my items
in my table, what
is the superset
or the set of
collection of attributes
so that I can understand
how to create my columns?
What are the data types
of those attributes?
And then, also, keep track
of any secondary indexes.
This sort of, if you do this as
a worksheet or, as like I said,
as homework, it sets you up
for a nice migration path.
First step is understand
the differences.
The data types are
generally there,
but there could be
some differences.
So understand how data types
from one map to the other.
Generally, you're going
to find all the same data
types if not more.
But this is the canonical
mapping of data types.
So let's make it practical.
Let's start with a
baseline DynamoDB table.
This is a table
you could create.
It's using a simplistic
hash key as its primary key.
It's not using hash and range.
And it's a hash key
called Username.
We have a little bit of
provisioned throughput.
And what I'm not
showing on here is
that, in order to facilitate
that streaming hook,
this table would also have
streams enabled, DynamoDB
streams, which would
just be another flag
on the end of this.
Or you could adjust your table.
If you have a table
that's already running,
you could simply augment
it and add streams to it.
So let's create the
equivalent table,
sort of taking that metadata we
went through, in the homework
collection, and we're going
to create the equivalent
table in Cloud Spanner.
And so let's say that we've
determined-- in that source
table, we've looked at
all the attributes inside
of our DynamoDB table and
decided that, really, there's
just sort of four consistent
attributes or four attributes
that represent the majority
of what we're looking at.
It's like Zipcode,
Subscribed, whether somebody's
subscribed to a
feed or not, when
they're sent a
reminder date, maybe
some points they've earned.
So this is a fictitious
table, but it's probably not
too dissimilar from
the way that you
would use a simple
database, a straightforward
database like DynamoDB that's
more key value oriented.
So we'll map that nicely
onto a Cloud Spanner schema.
To get to that point,
in the beginning,
I alluded, it's
actually really trivial.
This is almost the
entirety of what
you have to get going
with in Cloud Spanner.
Pick where you want it,
how much capacity you want,
and what you want to call it.
If you hit Create--
and I think you we'll
be showing this later.
If you hit Create,
it's a few seconds.
In a few seconds you've got that
much capacity sitting there.
And so in a three-node,
regional setup,
this is at roughly 30,000
reads a second, consistent,
with 6,000 writes a second.
So that's a lot of capacity,
especially when you're
talking about maybe dealing with
much lower capacity in terms
of provisioned throughput.
Just for three
nodes, you get a lot.
And three nodes would be kind
of the minimum for a production
sized setup.
There's also
multi-regional, which
implies more quorum copies.
I would encourage you
to go to a Cloud Spanner
101 talk to understand
how the quorum works,
and where the writes
are distributed.
But basically, if you do
this, within a few seconds,
you've got a tremendous
bucket of input output.
So that table I showed on the
previous screen that said, hey,
we've analyzed our
source table, figured out
how it looks in Dynamo,
figured out the columns,
how do we get the columns to
something database oriented?
So within the instance--
so in the previous
screen, I showed
how to create an instance--
within that instance,
we can now begin
instantiating databases.
Databases are sort of
logical containers.
The instance is the
ubiquitous sea of capacity.
And then the databases
are specific logical units
inside of that database
so you can create tables.
Looks and feels pretty much
like any other database.
It's really not that dissimilar.
But we take our DDL, which is
standard DDL, plug that in,
and we create our database.
One thing that we would do,
at this point, in our table,
is we'd run back to
our Dynamo table.
And using DynamoDB
Streams and Lambda,
we want to capture
all the changes off.
And so I would turn around.
I would make a
function like this,
a Lambda function like this.
And this becomes the glue
between all the changes
happening inside of
my DynamoDB table
and getting it over
to Google Cloud side.
And we're using basically
Pub/Sub in the middle.
So basically, what
I'm saying is,
inside of my Lambda
function, every time
I get a change, I've got my
DynamoDB Streams to configure,
to send me the new image.
With DynamoDB you
can say, send me
the old image, the
new image, or both.
And so all I'm doing is I'm
taking the entire payload ,
and I'm just shoving it over.
And this basically
has Lambda make a call
and sends it over to Pub/Sub.
We'll show this in
action in a minute.
So it's in Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is our highly scalable,
distributed messaging system,
in which case you can
be pumping messages in,
at a million a second or
something ridiculous, whatever
your application needs, and
have n number of subscribers.
They can be pull subscribers
or push subscribers,
where something is contacting
and pulling for messages,
or it can push to an endpoint,
any kind of endpoint,
like a Cloud
Function or whatnot.
We're going to be
using a pull mechanism.
This would be an
interesting time,
if your application had
the luxury, where you may--
this would be the inflection
point, at which you may decide,
hey, for consistency's
sake, let's do a quick pause
while we kick off an export.
It's not strictly
needed depending
on how much data
you think is going
to be mutated during this
time or overlap of keys.
But this would be that moment
you would decide, hey, we're
going to kick off an export.
Should we pause
writes for a second,
so that we can keep track
of exactly when this Lambda
function is instantiated and
when the export was kicked off.
It's a momentary thing that
you would have to decide.
It's not strictly needed.
So how do we get data?
So we've already put
in a Lambda function.
That's sending over
the streaming data.
Basically, now, how
do we do the bulk?
So that becomes our
checkpointing time.
Like we put in this function.
We've started collecting data.
It's changing as of this moment.
Now, how do we do
the mass export?
So you need to lean
into the platform that
hosts that data source.
In the case of DynamoDB,
there's a tool.
You can run a data pipeline job.
That is the canonical
way to get data out
if you were to go
and say Export.
But what it does is it lands
that data into an S3 bucket.
That kicks off an EMR process.
Elastic MapReduce process
reaches in the table
and then kicks out
flat files that
are JSON files and puts
those into an S3 bucket.
So if you think back
to the Lambda function,
that Lambda function
was our glue
that got us from
changes happening
in Dynamo over to Pub/Sub.
If you think about
our S3 bucket,
the glue that sort of
moves it from Amazon-side
to the Google-side
is a Copy command.
Before you do the Copy, you
just kind of look at the bucket.
There should be a
success file inside
of the export that
would tell you
that everything went correct.
But essentially, you
can use the gsutil--
it's the Google
Storage utility--
that understands how to read
Amazon credential files.
So this is a very handy feature.
Essentially, let's say,
you're working on an instance
or you're working
inside a Cloud Shell,
and you've installed the
Amazon command line utilities
and, obviously, now the
Google command line utilities,
including gsutil.
Gsutil knows how to read your
Amazon credentials if they're
configured on the same box.
And you can literally
pass it an S3 URL.
So, in this case, I can
say, go from the S3 bucket
to my cloud storage
bucket and rsync.
So just tell me
everything that's there.
If it's an especially
large transfer,
we have a background operation
called Cloud Storage Transfer
Service that will do this
for you in the background.
And now both sets of artifacts,
both the Pub/Sub streaming
changes as well as the
flat files from S3,
have shown up on the
Google side of the fence.
So what do we do
with those things?
The first thing is we do a job
to import all those flat files
from S3.
So we would kick
off a Dataflow job.
And Dataflow is
our managed service
for managing Apache
Beam pipelines.
And so we would have
a pipeline written,
an Apache Beam
pipeline that knows
how to take flat
files, in JSON format,
and write those into Cloud
Spanner using something
called SpannerIO, which is
a mechanism for Apache Beam
to write to Spanner.
And that would run through,
and that would complete.
And the nice thing
about Cloud Data Flows,
it takes your
Apache Beam pipeline
and then gives you this
very introspective view
into your pipeline, how it
is and how many messages
are being written, what
was the success factor.
And so you would monitor the
progress, verify item counts.
When it's done, perhaps do
some selects between the two
databases and make sure that
the item count between one table
and another table are the same.
And do some spot checking.
Look at the item in
one database and look
at the item in the other one.
You're going to want
to do this, maybe,
for different items
inside of your database.
So now the more interesting
challenge, which is how do you
get those streaming
changes, which
have been getting into the
Pub/Sub queue, which haven't
been picked up yet,
how do we get those out
and pushed into Spanner?
So now we want to create a
subscription to that topic
and run the same thing.
But this is now a streaming job.
This will not terminate
like the other job,
which was a batch job.
This is a streaming
job that kicks off.
And it's very similar.
This is a DAG structure,
which is like, essentially,
a structure of
activities that you've
asked to happen in a sequence.
And now the streaming pipeline
will stay and continue them.
It's not going to
terminate, because you
expect messages to keep coming
in until the migration is
done, right?
And what this does,
it's slightly different.
It's not just new records.
It has to look and see is this
a created or an update and/or
a delete.
This is because the
Spanner API calls
that do these are
slightly different.
And so you need to
separate this logic.
So I've shown you
some Dataflow code.
I don't want to make
this slide [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's show you some of
the background behind it.
So let's look at
the batch pipeline.
It's a little more concise for
the purposes of demonstration.
But this is Apache Beam code.
This is a kind of trimmed
down version of the pipeline.
You create these pipelines.
And you essentially
just create these stages
within your pipeline.
And this is a pretty
straightforward one.
You can annotate it with
a friendly name that
will be represented in the UI.
But I want to ReadItems.
I want to ParseItems.
I want to CreateMutations
and WriteItems.
It sounds pretty-- it sounds
like the canonical activities
that you would go through.
And let's look at one of these.
Let's look at like ParseItems,
which is basically,
how do I take that
in-coming JSON, that's
coming from the records
that are coming from Dynamo,
and how do I map those?
What is that step that
just said, ParseItems,
in my Apache Beam pipeline?
What that's doing
is it's mapping it
to a Java object in this case.
And so you would have
some code that just says,
hey, map JSON with Gson.
And now I've got this object
representation of each record
that's coming through.
So now that I've got each
record that's coming through,
the next thing in my pipeline
list was CreateMutations.
CreateMutations takes each
of these class members
now and sort of lets me
map them to column names.
This was the second
step in that pipeline.
And so, once that's
done, then, basically,
that pipeline has what it needs.
One thing I'll touch on is
the Dynamo, we mentioned,
that could have a
slightly different
primary key structure, which
would be hash and range.
This is where you would
take advantage of a feature
within Spanner, called
interleaved tables,
where one table can be nested
inside of another table
by attribution of a
commonly shared primary key
or the first part
of a primary key.
So if you notice,
these both share, say,
Username as a primary
key but also OrderNumber.
This physically co-locates
data that's like.
So if the primary key was
Niel, and then the next thing
was Niel and his
orders, those would
be sort of co-located from
a storage perspective.
They would be operated on by
the same nodes within Spanner.
Or they, technically,
would be in the same split,
so it would be managed
by the same nodes.
This makes things
like co-located
joins very fast and efficient.
Also, secondary indexes,
if you remember,
the original interrogation
was, are there
any secondary
indexes, any indexes
on non-primary key fields?
You would turn around
and, now, at the end,
would be the time to apply that.
And Spanner does the same thing.
If you don't have
a secondary index,
and you ran a query on
an non-primary key field,
you're essentially going to get
a full table scan coming back
at you.
So we want to create a secondary
index on whatever columns
are going to be
interesting to our query.
So I'll do a quick little
run through on verifying
replication.
This is demo time,
so this is usually
when the sweat beads start.
So if we could, I'll
cut through this.
All right.
So to be respectful of time,
I'm going to just sort of run
through some trivia.
I'm going to create three keys.
I'm going to deal with three
keys in my Dynamo table.
I'm going to have
my-add-key, my-change-key
and my-delete-key.
So the add one, I'm
going to add in,
see if it comes over to Spanner.
The change one, I'm going
to change an attribute.
And the delete one, I'm
going to get rid of.
I'm going to basically
see those happen,
and then walk through
everything that happened.
So let's just
verify a few things.
Number one is I
don't have a key.
I don't have the add key.
That's the one I'm
about to add in.
Let's look at the key
I'm going to change.
The key I'm going to
change, right now,
is currently set to False.
And so anybody want to
take a guess at what
I'm going to change it to?
True, all right.
And then lastly, I'm
going to run Delete,
and so there's a record there
that we're going to wipe away.
So let's go and mess with
these things on Dynamo-side.
So I'm in my Dynamo
table, and the first thing
is I'm going to
just add my-add-key,
and I'm going to add a
Boolean called Subscribed.
And I'm going to call it False.
So let's add that.
And I'm going to
also then modify--
I'm going to change this key.
If you remember,
it's set to false.
I'm going to set it to True.
So I'm going to change this key.
And the last thing is
I'm going to modify,
I'm going to get rid of--
OK.
So these are kind of the
canonical CRUD operations,
right?
What would happen if I changed,
what would happen if I--
thing?
So I've changed
everything on this side.
So let's look at our Lambda
function, real quick.
So our Dynamo table is
set up to have a trigger.
This trigger is DynamoDB
Spanner Lambda function,
that I showed earlier.
And this is that function.
Some things I'd point out is
that that function obviously
needs to operate
with some credentials
in order to talk
to the Google APIs.
Those credentials don't belong
in flat files or any sort
of extractable measure.
You're going to
want to set those
as environment variables
for your Lambda function.
And you would take the
entire service account JSON
and shove that in
as an environment
variable for your
function, let's say,
in this case, service account.
That is, in fact, not
my service account JSON.
And then let's check
Cloud Watch and see
if any logs came through.
So about the right time
that things came through.
So this is the key I added.
That timestamp should
be about right now.
I added my key.
And you can see that, basically,
new image, string, my-add-key,
Boolean False.
And then this is the key
thing to pay attention to
is Pub/Sub ID.
So that's the Lambda
function having contacted
Google Pub/Sub, and the Google
Pub/Sub API saying, here's
your Pub/Sub ID back.
And basically, my
change key, you
can see that the
new image is True.
The old image is False.
And my-delete-key you can
see that it was remove,
and it was removed.
So in Cloud Dataflow,
this pipeline is running.
Actually, I should
have shown that.
But this is currently running.
So this pipeline is
consistently running.
I should have shown
the counts beforehand.
But I missed that step.
But in the logs of
this, you can see
that, basically, the logging
for Pub/Sub subs says,
hey, three keys came by my way.
And so what it did is it
ran, for each of those keys,
it ran through this pipeline.
So that's already done.
Let's see if we go back through.
So before, we had a key
here, my-delete-key.
No results found.
So that's been wiped away.
That was the key we deleted out.
My change key, what
did I change it to?
True, right?
I flipped it from False to True.
And the other is add.
And it's there.
So that's effectively the
entirety of that pipeline.
It's actually a really,
really simple pipeline.
It's something you could
orchestrate pretty easily.
We plan to publish
it as a solution,
so that folks can download
it and try it on their own.
So that's it for me.
I'm gong to hand
it over to Niel.
NIEL MARKWICK: Let's see if
we switch this one first.
Yeah, I got it.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: You got it?
NIEL MARKWICK: Yep.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: You need this?
So Sami has shown you how to
use Dataflow as a streaming
pipeline, making
sure your changes go
from Dynamo to Spanner.
I'm going to do the big job,
which is the bulk import,
creating the Spanner instance
and importing all the data.
So like we said, four
clicks to create Spanner.
I'm going to create an instance.
I'm going to use
the musicbrainz--
yep, spelled it
correctly-- database.
And I'm going to configure
it in my home country,
europe-west1, which is Belgium.
Perhaps you've been
inside that data center.
It is massive.
I was expecting it to be
big, but it was bigger.
So we create 20 nodes.
This will give us
a database that
will be able to handle
40 terabytes of data,
200,000 reads per second,
and 40,000 writes per second.
And it's bigger than what we
need for Musicbrainz database,
but it's for getting the
demos happening speedily.
Here, we have our DDL,
which is simple CREATE.
TABLE you can see here that
I'm using a commits timestamp
on that row.
And as primary keys,
I'm using a hashed ID
as the initial primary key.
I'll explain that
in the next section.
So I'm just going to copy/paste
this into my Spanner creation.
Continue, Edit as
Text, bam, and Create.
And this is my fourth click.
So that creates my database.
And thank you.
And there I have
100-and-something tables
that are in the
musicbrainz database.
So now I want to import my data.
Well, Musicbrainz already
puts all their data
on their website as tabbed
delimited format export files.
So I put all those already
in a Cloud Storage bucket.
I have written a Dataflow
job, as Sami's explained,
with all the steps.
And I'm now going
to run that Dataflow
job to pull the files,
in the source paths,
from this cloud storage bucket.
I'm putting it in
this new database
that I've just created.
So I just copy that and run it.
And this simple build, run step
with Maven, and it started.
And in a couple of
seconds, it will
initiate the Dataflow job to
start bulk importing the data.
Yep, there it goes in theory.
There we go.
So this Dataflow job, as
Sami explained earlier--
graph is still being analyzed.
There we go.
So it looks at this
cloud storage bucket,
gets the list of
files to import.
It reads the tab
delimited format files,
gets each line,
which is a single row
in the original database.
We create the Spanner mutation,
passing the data in that row,
converting it to
the Spanner types.
And then, because
it's a batch job,
I'm going to batch
these mutations together
in groups of 100.
And then write these
batches of 100 to Spanner.
It's more efficient to write
batches of rows to Spanner
than it is to write
individual rows.
And this job is now running.
Dataflow uses
Compute Engine VMs.
And you can see, here,
if I refresh that page,
it's created a bunch of VMs--
there we go-- a bunch of VMs
to run those Dataflow steps.
Each of those boxes can be
run on individual nodes,
with Dataflow managing
the data, passing
between one and the other.
And it will alter scale,
high and low, too.
And it's just going now.
So it's read, so far,
78 files, 234 files.
And it's starting to read them.
So, we'll let that go running.
And we'll come back to it at
the end of the next section.
So as Sami talked
about NoSQL, and I'm
going to have to run
through this quickly,
because we've got less time
than we thought we had.
Sami talked about NoSQL.
I'm going to be talking about
the relational database side
import.
My examples would
be MySQL, specific,
but the general case applies
to most relational databases.
So Sami's already
talked about why.
The advantages are
reasonably obvious,
no planned downtime, no ops.
Everything is managed view.
Operating system, hardware
and software updates
happen all in the background.
Horizontally scaled, so
you can just add more power
when you want to.
No sharding.
You've got a globally
consistent view
of your data and
external consistency,
with ACID-compliant
write transactions.
Read transactions
allow you to read data
at a particular timestamp,
up to an hour old.
And you've also got
ANSI-2011 SQL queries.
So the first thing
you want to do
is look at your existing schema
and check the data types.
Spanner has a very
concise set of data types.
There's just this
little bunch here.
All of these can
be actually used
as keys apart from
the ARRAY type.
The ARRAY type can be of
any of the other types.
So you want to look at
your existing schema
and map the existing data
types to the Cloud Spanner data
types.
Many of them have
a direct mapping.
But some of them, as you
can see in this list,
do not have a direct mapping.
In this case, you want to
change your application database
access layer, like
we mentioned earlier,
to convert from your
internal representation
to an equivalent
Spanner representation.
So, for instance, an ENUM, you'd
write to Spanner as a string,
and you'd pass it back
out in your application.
Table keys are important
consideration in Spanner.
In traditional
databases, you often
work with sequences, where
your rows increase constantly.
That is an anti-pattern
in Spanner,
because Spanner splits the data
into multiple splits, sorted
by a primary key.
And when you add data,
it's added to the split.
So if you've got a sequential
key, always increasing,
it will always be added
to the last split.
And if you're doing that a
lot, then you're last bit
becomes the only split where
there's any database activity.
It becomes a hotspot.
And you may have 20
nodes, but you're only
using one to write your data.
So what do you do about this.
Well, you need to prefix
your keys with another key
in order to distribute
the data better.
Now, if it is a
greenfield database,
you'd probably use a
unique UID or a random key.
But because we're
importing, we want
to keep this sequential key.
So what do we do?
Well, we add a hash.
We simply do a simple
hash of the original key
and prefix that in the
Spanner primary key.
So you see, on the second
row, the primary key
has a hashed ID, which, in
this case, of just a CRC32.
It doesn't have to be secure.
It just has to be somewhat
random but deterministic,
based on the original ID.
There is lots of documentation,
on Cloud.Google.com,
about how to hash
keys and other details
in which to avoid
hotspots in Cloud Spanner
by using this feature.
Of course, if you
have referential keys,
you need to include the
hash key in the reference.
Because it's the primary
key of the existing table,
so you need to
include the hashed key
in the referenced table.
This is to avoid
a full-scale table
scan, when you are
wanting to look up
the keys, when you do a join.
Once the application
has been fully migrated,
you can do another
migration, if you want to,
which is to remove
all the sequences
and switch everything
to unique UIDs.
Secondary indexes
in Spanner are also
implemented by tables
under the hood.
So the exact same problem
occurs with columns
that you've got in an index.
In this case, we're indexing
events by timestamp.
Timestamp, of course, is a
continuously increasing key.
And you'll get a
hotspot, because you're
adding more and more
events, increasing in time,
so you're getting a hotspot.
What you do here?
Well, you do something called
application level sharding,
which is creating a shard ID.
This is not the
same as a split ID.
It's just an application-defined
value to mix up the data a bit.
In this case, I'm using
the CRC32 of the timestamp,
module at 100, which
gives you a number
from 0 to 99, which is
relatively random based
on the timestamp.
I add this into the table,
and I index on that timestamp
shard ID, so that way
the index, itself,
is randomly distributed.
If we want to SELECT from the
index using a range select,
I have to include
all the shards.
Because, otherwise, again,
because it's the key,
Spanner will do a table scan.
So again, I'm selecting, using
the BETWEEN clause there,
shards 0 to 99, and then
using the range clause.
And that gives a limited SELECT
and not a full table scan.
Sequences do not exist in Cloud
Spanner, because, as I said,
it's an anti-pattern.
So for that, you have
to implement them
in your application.
The simplest way is to have a
table in your database called
Sequences, with the sequence
name and the next identifier.
When you want to add
a row to your table,
you get the next ID.
You increment it and update
your Sequences table,
and then you insert your new row
with, obviously, the hashed ID
and the new sequence number.
This is fine for a
rarely modified table.
But if you've got
something happening a lot,
this, of course,
becomes a choke-point.
Every insert will have to
wait on the Sequences table
to do the update.
We've gone a bit too
far for myself, there.
So the way to
avoid that would be
to get each application instance
to manage a block of sequences,
so to read, say, 100
sequences from the table,
manage them internally, issuing
the sequence IDs to itself.
It means you'll lose
the continuous value
of the sequence to
a certain degree.
But, as I said, continuous
keys are not the best plan
in Spanner, in any case.
Foreign key constraints--
Spanner gives a lot
performance benefits
by trusting the application
to keep the data consistent.
And one of these things is not
having foreign key constraints
in other tables.
This, you can have to
implement in the application
if you want it.
But in most
applications, it already
knows what data is there,
what data isn't there.
And so you wouldn't
be able to create--
the application shouldn't
be able to create
an object without the parent
object already existing.
If you do want to add
foreign key constraints,
you can easily do it yourself,
in the database access layer,
simply by checking for the
existence of a reference table
key.
And if it doesn't exist,
throw an exception.
And if it does, then
you're insert your row,
and there's a foreign
key constraint check
implemented application side.
Similarly, ON DELETE
and ON UPDATE rules
must also be implemented
in the application,
because there's no
foreign key constraints.
You find all the child IDs that
are referenced by the parent.
You delete them all.
And then you delete your parent.
That's an ON Delete
CASCADE rule, of course.
ON DELETE UPDATE
or ON DELETE set
Null would be implemented
by updating the rows
or abandoned in transaction
should any child rows be there.
As Sami already mentioned,
the interleaved parent-child
relationship does have
referential integrity
constraints and ON DELETE rules.
So here, we have a
parent and a child.
We've told it to
interleave in the parents.
ON DELETE CASCADE, Sami's
mentioned, in detail,
about that.
I'm going to just skip over it.
But in this case, there is
a foreign key constraint.
And the child table
key must reference
the key of the parent.
And in an ON DELETE CASCADE
rule, it'll delete the parent,
it deletes the children.
You can create a
hierarchy of six levels
of tables in this manner.
But be aware,
because all the child
tables have to be in the same
split as a top level row.
The four gigabyte
size split limit
applies to the size of the top
level row and all its children.
That hasn't happened
very often, but I
have had a customer that thought
they would meet that problem.
Commit timestamps I mentioned.
You define them in the schema
with an options clause.
In the application,
you use a special value
to insert the commit
timestamp, and then you
can use that during
the migration process
to detect whether a row
has later or earlier data.
I'm really rushing
through this, because I
can see the clock counting
down quite rapidly.
Other things that
you'd have to monitor
are on the application side.
Default values, easy to put
in your database access layer.
Stored procedures
and triggers-- well,
do to the distributed
architecture,
trigger is bit of an
anti-pattern you can easily
implement in your application.
And because Spanner
is effectively
infinitely scalable,
you don't have
a worry about running
triggers and stored procedures
in the database.
You can just have more nodes,
and everything runs better.
It also gives you the benefit
that the stored procedure
and triggers you put
in your business logic,
in the application, with
the rest of the code.
And you can have it written
in the same language.
You can unit test it without
needing a test database
instance.
Per table access privileges
don't exist in Spanner.
Your access control
is read or write
using the Cloud
Platform IAM controls
for the whole database.
And finally-- sorry,
whoop, go back--
JDBC.
It's currently read-only.
And there is no data
modification language
currently.
But right at this moment,
there is a second Spanner talk
going on, over in Moscone South,
where Deepti, our Cloud Spanner
PM, is announcing that data
modification language is
being previewed right now.
And there'll be a read/write
JDBC wrapper coming soon.
We got a minute or so left, so
let's have a look at my demo
and see if everything's run OK.
So back to the Dataflow
view, what have we got?
So we've read 234 source files.
From that, we've got
20 million records.
We're adding to Spanner at
the rate of 31,000 per second,
batching them, of course.
Down to 300 batches
per second or so.
And let's have a look
at the logged failures.
There have been no failures
and 21 million successes.
And just to show that
this is for real,
I'm going to go, stop this
job, give my database a rest.
Where are we?
Spanner.
Let's have a look at
the artist credit table.
And let's have a look
at some of the data.
So here, when the data
finally comes out--
hello, Spanner.
The demigods are
not smiling on me
with 20 seconds counting
down on the clock.
There we go.
So here, we see that
the data has been added.
The original, sequential IDs
have been prefixed by a hash
and, therefore, being completely
mixed up in a random order.
And if I just want to
run a query on that data,
we'll run a simple query
selecting all the recordings
that have the word
cloud in their name,
joining them with the artist,
and see what we get out.
Query, bum, bum, bum--
there we go.
Let's run this query.
This, when I tested
it yesterday,
took about five seconds.
Because it's a
demo, it's probably
going to take 10
times as long, and I
could be sitting here talking
to myself for five minutes.
Yeah.
So once the query comes
back, having scanned
its several million
rows, because, of course,
I am not using an index key, I'm
using a table scan on the name.
What we'll do is we'll let that
run, because the demo gods are
obviously not smiling
on me, but run
through a quick, last
couple of slides,
and we'll come back to this.
Other things to wrap up?
Tomorrow, there's talk on
how Nest Camera service has
moved to Google Cloud.
They were originally on Amazon,
when Google acquired them.
And they've just completed
a massive migration.
So all the camera services,
all your recordings on Nest
are now on Google Cloud.
Niantic are going to talk
about moving to Cloud Spanner.
Niantic are the people behind
Ingress and Pokemon Go.
And "Reinventing Databases for
Your Journey to the Cloud."
In the archives,
from yesterday, there
was Optiva, who migrated
from Oracle to Cloud,
and their lessons learned.
Bandai Namco, how are
they using Cloud Spanner?
And the session that
I just mentioned,
"See What's New with
Cloud Spanner," which
is happening right this minute.
I'm going to restart my query,
because it appears to have
got stuck just to annoy me.
And finally, a quote
from Optiva saying,
when they moved from
Oracle to Spanner,
they could process 10
times more transactions
at 1/10 of the cost.
So they're obviously very happy
with the migration from Oracle
to Spanner.
One other thing I'd
just like to announce
is, tomorrow, which
is Cloud Hero.
And here is my cape, because
I am apparently a Cloud Hero.
It's a DevOps-style game, where
you race against the clock
to meet challenges.
So I now have my cape.
And if we go back
to the demo, it
has finally finished it's query.
We have a bunch of tracks,
with their artist, who
I have never heard of before.
And there we go.
And that's basically covered it.
We've got a little
bit over time.
I'm sorry about that.
If you have any questions--
how much time do we have left?
None.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN:
Just find us outside.
Thank you, everybody.
NIEL MARKWICK: Catch us outside.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN:
Thanks for attending.
NIEL MARKWICK: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]